[MUSIC PLAYING]
LORRAINE CINK: Marvel Studios'
Eternals introduces us
to some incredible
new superpowers,
which is why I'm
speaking with VFX
supervisor, Stephane Ceretti.
Hey, Steph.
Hey, Lorraine.
LORRAINE CINK: The first time we
get to see the Eternals' powers
in modern day is when
they're in London,
and they take on
the deviant, Kro.
Could you talk us
through that scene?
Well, it's a
sequence that comes
a little bit early in the film.
You've seen a bit of the
Deviants in past times,
but in this moment we
really introduce the leader
of the deviants, which is Kro.
Sersi, played by Gemma
Chan, lives in London,
so we had that beautiful
location of Camden.
So the deviant have
come from the river.
Sersi does a bit
of transmutation
on the ground to
fight that deviant.
There's also Sprite
that uses illusions
to kind of confuse the deviant,
and Icarus shows up and flies.
So it was a good way to
introduce the characters.
You had to work with
the incredible director,
Chloe Zhao.
Did she give you any
particular direction as you
began to work on this scene?
She comes with a background
of shooting on location,
shooting in nature.
So one of the approach
for the filming
was really to try and shoot on
location as much as possible.
So we tried to keep the shoot
as loose as possible to really
frame the actors, how they move
and how the camera is moving.
Chloe really likes very
wide lenses as well,
so you see a lot of the
environment all the time, which
creates some complication
for us because you
see much more than you usually
see when you use longer lenses.
Definitely.
So let's talk about a
few of these moments,
like when Sprite manifests all
of these different illusions
of her and Sersi in order
to confuse the deviant, Kro.
What was the process like
for creating that sequence?
We had to do a mixture
of shooting on location,
then shooting multiple passes
with motion-control cameras
of the actresses on
a blue-screen stage,
and being in different
positions for every shot,
creating that
library of elements
and, matching the light
that we had on the bridge.
And then also, further
away from the camera,
we could use digital doubles.
So animated versions
of Sprite and Sersi
that we could duplicate and
animate in the background,
and make it feel like
there's multiple versions
of the two characters.
LORRAINE CINK:
That's incredible.
All right, let's talk
about one of the moments
that is so surprising,
but also so beautiful.
That moment when Sersi turns
the bus into rose petals.
What was the process like for
bringing that moment to life?
One complexity
of that moment was
to make it a believable moment.
So the premise was really
mostly about trying
to find the right dynamic, the
right animation for the bus,
and for Icarus and
Kro hitting it.
So that was pretty important
for us to know all the distance
and the speed of the
bus, and where everybody
had to be at that
moment to make sure
that everything was in place.
Then after that, we had a
bus on the day for the shoot.
The bus that you actually
see coming in the street
is a digital bus.
We scanned the bus--
the London bus-- and
replicated it in the computer,
and it's a digital bus.
The only thing that we had left
of the bus, really, at the end
was the actual bus driver who is
a real bus driver from London.
The idea was that he was
buried under these pedals--
pretty much all the petals
you see in the sequence
are digital.
We had a few little red
petals on the floor,
but clearly not enough to do
everything we needed to do.
I really like the
moment of the bus,
actually, because I really like
the unexpected nature of it.
We tend to do a lot of
destruction in our films,
you know, and this wasn't
a moment like that.
It was a moment of
danger that transforms
into a moment of beauty.
And it's kind of
magical and whimsical.
It makes the movie a little
bit unique, in that sense.
The scene is so
incredible, but looking
back at the entire film,
what are you most proud of?
There's so many
things in this film.
We're creating all
these old civilisations,
and we're nowadays,
and then there's
stuff happening in space.
We've really worked really hard
to trying to convey the idea
that the events
that were happening
were happening on
a planetary level.
Conveying that scale in
simulation and effects
and all that stuff was
really complicated.
I'm very proud of what the teams
at our visual effects studios
have done, and how much they've
put their heart into it.
Absolutely excellent work,
and thank you so much, Steph.
You're welcome.
Thank you so much.
Everyone, go experience
Marvel Studios'
Eternals, only in theaters now.